We can add an axis to our chart simply by calling an axis method and
the chart object.
Since our x axis represents years, we use the addTimeAxis method and
specify that the x axis should correspond to the year field of our data.
Let's finish this by adding a semicolon, which is not only a good
JavaScript best practice, but in some cases your code will run into errors if
you don't include one after every line, and then add an axis to our chart.
Previously, we tried to inspect my chart and it was quite hard to understand
what all the methods and properties meant, but let's inspect our x axis.
If we look here, its a dimple.axis object, and
it specified the chart it belongs to, the position,
in this case the x axis, and also what fields it corresponds to.
Something to note here,
that the chart property define our axis actually is a reference to
the chart object we created earlier, rather than just an identifier string.
And we've tried printing out what this chart object is x.chart,
we get the same object as we got when we printed out myChart.
As you can see here, they're both dimple.chart objects and
they both have all of the same properties.
Now this is possible even if two objects aren't identical, but
if they have the same properties defined.
Going one step farther,
we can actually compare the myChart object with the triple equals to x.chart.
In this case, it says myChart is exactly equal to the axis chart property.